Chris Cuomo continues his battle against
kovat 19 you know the CNN star shocked a
lot of people when he took on the media
but now he is clarifying his comments I
don't like what I do professionally I've
decided I don't think it's worth my time
the New York Post described it as a
meltdown but Chris says his words were
taken out of context I have never been
in a better position professionally than
I am right now I was talking about
having legitimate questions which I've
had all along this administration let
alone with a fever with Kovan for two
weeks and being sick and rethinking a
lot of things on an existencial basis
over time you can't fault the CNN news
man he's been going live every weeknight
quarantined in his basement and was
close to going 72 hours without a fever
one of the indicators that would have
allowed him to end self-isolation
I got close I got to 60 and I have to be
honest I got a little cocky my body's
not ready till it's ready and all I know
is I'm gonna throw everything I can at
this Cuomo is self distancing from his
three children and his wife of almost 19
years Kristina all have tested negative
for Kovan 19 so far I here at home with
Kristina and you know and that's my
biggest concern that you know she
doesn't go the wrong way the kids don't
go the wrong way
Kristina wellness guru has been sharing
a detailed journal of Chris's recovery
and included a shout out to Iron Man
himself Robert Downey jr. sent Chris
natural remedies like vitamin C and B
packets
thank you I'm one of the lucky ones
[Music]